nos piden graficar la desigualdad y es
menor que 3 x 5 ok entonces si nos dan
una equis y déjenme etiquetar aquí los
ejes este es el eje x y este es el eje y
entonces si nos dan alguna equis digamos
que x es igual a 1 justo aquí entonces 3
x x + 5 sería 3 x 1 + 5 que es 8 verdad
entonces subimos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8
entonces esto me está diciendo que ya
debe ser menor que 8 que es 3 x 1 + 5
verdad así que los valores de ya que
satisfacen esta restricción para la x
son todos estos de aquí abajo déjenme
hacerlo en un color más
más clarito muy bien entonces para x
igual a 1 serían todos estos valores de
aquí abajo sin incluir ye igual a 8
verdad porque tiene que ser menor
estricto que 8 ahora si seguimos
haciendo esto esencialmente vamos a
graficar la línea de igual a 3 x + 5 sin
incluir la línea podríamos incluir todo
lo demás debajo de ella como lo hicimos
en este punto pero no la línea así que
ya sabemos cómo graficar esto déjenme
escribirlo por aquí así que si vamos a
graficar igual a 3 x + 5
entonces decimos la pendiente es 3 y la
ordenada al origen de 5 es decir el
punto donde se intersecta con el eje y
entonces para graficar eso simplemente
vamos a empezar graficándolo como una
línea punteada y empezamos con la
intersección en el eje que es aquí esta
es la intersección con el eje y y la
pendiente es 3 así que subimos por cada
uno de x 3 d llega
entonces más o menos se vería algo así
así estos puntos estarían en la línea ok
entonces si nos vamos para atrás
agregamos estos puntos este punto y este
punto ok y los conectamos ahora con una
línea punteada
así que está esta línea punteada es la
gráfica de igual a 3 x 5 pero no la
vamos a incluir ok por eso la pusimos de
forma punteada ahora cualquier para
cualquier otro x digamos para x igual a
menos 1 si evaluamos 3 x 5 en esa x
bueno solo nos fijamos en las yes que
son estrictamente menor a ese valor que
obtuvimos de ella entonces son todos los
que están debajo de la línea para
cualquier x que tomemos
todo lo que está debajo de la línea es
parte de la solución
toda esta área déjenme déjenme dibujarlo
con un color más oscuro entonces vamos a
iluminar toda el área debajo de esta
línea
toda esta entonces toda esta área es
menor que 3 x 5